[Music]
americans
love their pets and they continue to
spend more and more money on them in
aggregate
more than the economic output of some
entire countries but is this pet mania
actually making americans happy let's
take a look
for every group spending any time with
pets is associated
with lower life satisfaction spending
any time with pets is associated with
significant declines in happiness
though not as severe as living with your
parents or being disabled or unemployed
but pet ownership is clearly no
replacement for things like getting
married or having children
now while we can't use this
cross-sectional data to say too much
about causality
we can conclude a few things a pet might
moderate
effects of loneliness or unemployment
but it doesn't fully counteract it
whatever positive happiness benefits
pets may give their owners
it's not enough to offset other sources
of sadness and loneliness which is why
pet owners tend to be less happy
ultimately pets are no substitute for
the connection of human family
[Music]
so what do you think are pets family
members let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei